here are the top three first moves in
chess we're gonna start first with the
King Pawn moving at two squares is a
great way to begin this allows these two
pieces the queen and Bishop to get out
next and it also controls these two very
important Central light squares this is
actually the most popular first move for
new players and what's the favorite
first move of American World chess
champion Bobby Fisher white now only
needs to develop their bishop and Knight
next to get castled and be off to a
great start our second most popular move
is to advance the queen pull in two
squares this allows this bishop to get
up next and controls the two very
important Central dark squares unlike
the King Pawn this Pawn is protected by
the queen as a result White's position
feels a little more secure and safe as
it's getting going our third option is
to move the Knight here unlike moving
the pawns this gets a minor piece out
immediately and controls these two
Central squares this is a very flexible
choice because you can still choose
multiple ways to advance your pawns next
likely depending on what your opponent
does